[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
BRYNN EVANS: I'm Brynn
Evans, and I'm really
excited to be hosting
this conversation today
about what I consider
to be one of the hardest
things in design-- hiring and
building out a great design
team.
I think this is challenging
for a number of reasons.
For one, designers
are hard to come by.
There's a lot of us in
the audience here today,
but a lot of designers
are happy in their jobs,
and it's hard to convince them
to consider a new opportunity.
I think recruiters
face this a lot.
I think as design managers,
we face this a lot.
Once you've got designers
recruited onto your teams,
growing their skills,
and their talents,
and keeping them motivated and
engaged is really challenging.
Smart people are
hard to keep engaged.
And thirdly, I feel
that as you grow
your team or the needs of your
organization change over time,
you need to constantly be
reevaluating your hiring
practices, where your needs are.
And so you're just constantly
revisiting this timely question
of hiring and building
out great teams.
So for me, this is particularly
timely, because I've recently
switched teams at Google,
as John mentioned.
I was on a pretty large team
on Google+ for a long time,
and I was helping with
hiring, and sourcing,
and recruiting there.
But what I found is
because I could staff
for a really large team, I
could find the best talent
and find a good role for
them on the broader team.
And suddenly, I've
switched roles,
and I'm on a much
smaller team in Android.
It really operates a
lot more like a startup,
and I manage two designers
and one researcher.
And suddenly, I want
to hire a new designer,
and I have to be really picky
about filling that role,
because I only have one slot.
And yet, I need this person
to have really specific skills
to help me in really
specific ways, suddenly.
So I've noticed, again,
needs shifting over
the course of changing jobs,
and roles, and things like that.
So to get started, I'd like
to have the panelists quickly
introduce themselves,
say something
about their role and
their background,
especially as it
pertains to hiring
and your experiences in the
past, and a point of view
that you have on hiring
or some perspective.
MIA BLUME: Cool.
So hey, everyone.
I'm Mia.
I manage product
designers at Pinterest.
Before Pinterest,
I was at Square,
so similar growth trajectory
but very different
product and relatively
different culture.
And before that, I was
at IDEO for a while,
which is a completely
different hiring spectrum.
So from a design manager
leadership perspective,
one of the things that
I try and think about
is designing the team.
If you look at a description
for any design leadership role,
you'll see things like scale
the team, deliver great work,
engage your designers,
all business talk.
But at the end of the
day, we're designers.
We know how to create complex
systems, interactions,
communication flows,
and environments
that are really
successful and creative.
So that's definitely
a motto that I
bring to the table in terms
of how do we cultivate
a great culture, how do we
think about the composition
of our team, and how do
we all work together?
One of the things that
I've learned along the way,
just like being a designer,
being a design manager
or leader, you have
to take some risks.
And you're going to fail, and
that's OK, just like the things
that you're building
every single day.
But you've got to
try something new.
And what works for me may not
work for these guys, and so on.
So taking risk and
trying new things.
And the last thing.
This is particularly
true for us at Pinterest,
but I think it's true for all
of us because we're creatives.
The most important
thing, I think,
in terms of keeping
your designers engaged
is making sure that you
have an inspired team.
If your designers are
inspired, whether it's
by each other, the projects
that they're working on,
the environment
they're in, they're
more likely to create an
inspiring and creative product.
SOLEIO CUERVO: Hey, everyone.
My name is Soleio.
I was at Facebook
from 2005 to 2011.
I was Facebook's second
product designer.
While there, I got to work
on a bunch of core products,
building out a lot of our
early features for our users,
and overseeing our
visual design standards,
and overseeing a
lot of our growth.
The reason why I'm here is
along with building products
with my colleagues there, I
was responsible for helping
to bring and attract
a lot of our talent
to the design organization as
we went through hyper-growth.
After Facebook,
I joined Dropbox,
where I led design
from 2012 to 2014,
where we oversaw the growth
of the design team from about
three people all the
way through to-- I
think today we have
about 40-some designers
in the organization.
I wanted to come here
to talk to you guys
about understanding
core motivation.
I think that at the end of
the day, any organization,
its real competitive
edge is aligning people
to what the business
is setting out to do.
And within the
design discipline,
it's understanding a
person's core motivation
for being a designer.
What gets them up
in the morning?
What is their dream work?
What is their dream gig?
Who are the people that they
want to be affiliated with?
What's the kind
of work that they
want to be affiliated with?
Whether it be craftsmanship,
whether it be illustration,
whether it be
visual storytelling,
it's really important for you to
be able to concretely identify
what a person wants to do as
a designer, what brought them
into the field.
And the thing that
actually worked for us
a great deal at Dropbox
was asking that question,
having that conversation,
understanding
what led you to
become a designer.
What is it that you take
pride in in your work?
What's the sort of
thing that you'll
do that you don't
have to be paid for?
And what are clever ways, from
an interviewer's standpoint,
to solicit that?
We found that just by asking
the question, like, show
us some side projects
that you've worked on,
what are the things that you've
done that you haven't been paid
for, what's your proudest
design collaboration,
you can learn a
lot of things about
whether or not a
person is not just
a great technical fit
for your organization,
but also a great culture fit.
One of the things
that we did at Dropbox
was articulate a set
of values around how
we want to conduct ourselves
as people, as a business,
and make sure that those
values are described as hiring
attributes that we embed in our
hiring standards-- making sure
that every single person that
we're hiring into Dropbox
exhibits the qualities
of being humble,
being audacious,
people who are really
passionate about
[? the ?] details,
and people who are going
to be really trustworthy.
Because it follows
that you're not
going to build software
that's going to help people
collaborate, you're not
going to build software
that people are going to really
trust unless you hire folks who
themselves are worthy of trust.
DANIEL BURKA: Hey.
My name's Daniel, and
I'm a design partner
at Google Ventures.
So Google Ventures is
Google's venture capital arm.
We invest in about
250 companies.
And that means that
I, as a designer,
get to work with
those 250 companies
to help them to be
more successful.
Previously, I've helped
run a couple of startups
and founded one-- two.
Two startups.
So I have a lot of experience
in the startup world.
Now it's really
interesting to be
on the other side of
the fence and to get
to work with a wide variety
of startups-- everything
from life sciences
to consumer internet.
And one of the things that
they often come to us with
is, like, oh, hey, we heard
design is like this pixie dust,
or we know that
we suck at design,
and we want to hire a designer.
And design's a really big term.
And so we often help them to
either look at their design
needs either as
filling the gaps,
filling the holes
in their business,
or looking at where the
biggest opportunities are
in their business.
And even a small
startup that doesn't
have a designer,
somebody who wears
fancy clothes and a
cardigan, somebody's
doing the design
at that business.
And so what we'll frequently
do is talk to them
about the different
design skills.
And we'll talk about visual
design, front-end development,
copyrighting, product
interaction, and research.
If you really roughly
cut up design,
you might be able
to do it that way.
And then you look
at their business
and say, well, where are
you guys the strongest?
And maybe they have somebody
who's doing some copywriting
or doing some research.
But if you look at it-- and
the engineering-heavy team
might have great UI
development already,
but they're weak on the visual
interaction standpoints.
And that helps them
focus in on-- instead
of trying to post a job listing
for a unicorn-type designer
and go really broad
across everywhere,
it helps them really focus
in and hone their pitch,
hone who they're looking for,
and find the person who's
really going to help
them out the most.
SHALIN AMIN: So
my name's Shalin.
I'm the Creative
Director at Uber.
And I kind of want
to start off with I
guess an intro to myself.
So I started off at an
agency called Hot Studio back
in-- I don't really
remember the year.
Probably like six years ago.
And I worked out of their
San Francisco office,
went to New York to
help them establish
a presence in New York.
And then shortly after, I left
to work on my own startup.
In consulting, you
tend to go pretty wide.
You go understand
different verticals,
such as automotive, and
health care, and science.
But you never really see a
product from beginning to end.
And so I was at a
point where I decided
I wanted to see what it takes to
build a product from beginning
to end, and decided to
build my own startup.
And so that process
and journey led me
to doing a round of
funding, essentially.
And I was approached by Designer
Fund [? Rights, ?] pitched,
and met a couple
of mentors, and got
in touch with Travis at Uber.
And so that was the start
of my journey at Uber
and how I kind of got there.
So I wanted to touch
on growth at Uber.
We're about four, four
and a half years old.
And growth has been
pretty incredible for us.
And so I wanted to
throw out some numbers
around how fast we've grown over
the last two and a half years.
Since March 2012-- so
today is September 2014--
it's quite staggering
growing a team from one
to x in just a short
period of time.
And I'm hoping to
kind of cover some
of the hiring practices,
challenges, and failures
that we've gone through.
So the three things that we
typically look for at Uber
when we're hiring, and then
how we measure success,
basically, around the
work, we define it
with speed, vision, and quality.
All three are
essentially required.
It's not like you have to be
amazing at quality and speed
but not have vision.
And during our
evaluation process,
we also fine-tune and calibrate
for speed, vision, and quality.
This is essentially what
we look for in candidates
when we're looking
at portfolios.
And then the first
part is about the work
itself, and then how
they did the work.
So that involves, what
does the process look like?
Do they work well with
ambiguity, constraints?
Do they have an ego?
Do they work hard?
And then overall
communication, personal
and interpersonal communication.
Yeah.
BRYNN EVANS: Thanks.
As you guys are talking, you've
all sort of touched on this,
but I'm curious if there is
one greatest challenge for you
in the hiring process.
DANIEL BURKA: Sourcing.
BRYNN EVANS: Sourcing?
SOLEIO CUERVO: It's
basically identifying talent.
Sort of if you take
this statement,
break it into two chunks, how
do you identify people out
there in the universe
that are great designers
or can be great designers.
And two, how do you bring
them to your organization?
BRYNN EVANS: So what do you do?
DANIEL BURKA: Hey, if any of
you guys are looking for a job,
come talk to us.
[LAUGHTER]
BRYNN EVANS: So
that's what you do?
DANIEL BURKA: That's one way.
BRYNN EVANS: You get up on
stage and you make a pitch?
No, where do you
find talent, though?
SHALIN AMIN: I think
there's a variety of places.
So at Uber, specifically,
we didn't really
have recruiters at
the very beginning.
So we were leaning
on the networks
that we had amongst
friends and other people
that we had worked
with in the past.
And now, luckily,
we have a couple
of recruiters that
will go out and scan
the world for Dribbble, and
LinkedIn, and so on and so
forth, all the natural sources.
But most of the
success that we've had
has come through our networks
of designers that we've hired.
And really, when somebody's
able to step up to the plate
and be like, I have a friend
who's really great at x, y,
and z, we typically
don't hesitate
to reach out and contact them.
But most of our talent
comes from in house.
MIA BLUME: Actually, I think
one of the larger challenges
is getting the timing right.
So not just having
this source list
of designers or a
pool of designers
that you want to talk
to, but the timing.
So engaging with them
at the right time,
because most designers
out there have great jobs.
And so knowing how to build
a relationship with them
over a period of
time and knowing
when the timing is right.
BRYNN EVANS: How do you
do that at Pinterest?
MIA BLUME: A lot
of it is the team.
So networks, I think,
are the strongest way
to bridge the gap between these
two different problem sets.
So finding people that
you want to work with,
but also getting them in
and working with them.
So having the designers actually
engage in the community,
be out there, build
relationships with designers,
bring them over, have lunch
with them, whatever it is,
depending on that designer.
But knowing that
it may be a longer
game than a couple
of weeks or a month.
BRYNN EVANS: Yeah.
I've noticed that, too.
I feel like it's easier said
than done in a lot of ways.
I've been on both sides of
it, where there's candidates
I'm interested in,
and then I need
to remember to stay
in touch with them
and keep them on
the long-term radar
even if they're not
available right now.
And in turn, I've
also experienced that.
People keep up those sorts
of relationships with me.
I think, as a design
manager, we have
a lot of other responsibilities,
and so I think it's interesting
how you could balance that.
Do you work with recruiters
at your companies?
Do you manage your
relationships all yourselves?
Do you try to put some
of this onto your team
and get them engaged and active?
What do you do?
SOLEIO CUERVO: I
think the key piece
is to build a culture
around recruiting.
What's enjoyable about this
line of work in particular
is how collaborative it is.
And in order for you to build
a healthy design culture
and design organization
is that you
need to be really proactive
about the people that
populate it.
And so, at least at Dropbox
and certainly at Facebook,
a tremendous amount
of our hiring
came just from referrals
and from people
not just referring
their buddies or people
they've worked with in the
past, but naming their heroes,
naming the people
out there that are
producing really
great work, and not
being shy about cold-calling
these folks and saying, hey,
we want to have a
conversation with you.
We want to invite you to
work with us on this project.
At Dropbox, we found a
tremendous amount of success
through on-site contracting--
bringing people in for two-
to three-month stints,
giving them a desk,
giving them a laptop,
basically fully integrating
them into the team, and
then later, using that
as a means of starting
the conversation
around full-time employment.
And again, if you make that
list of people who you're really
passionate about, but more
importantly, you feel deep down
are correctly aligned
with what you're
trying to accomplish
as a business,
that can get you
much further along
than just wishing
them to join you.
BRYNN EVANS: I think that's
an interesting strategy,
actually-- not something
that we do a lot at Google.
But I've wondered
about in the past,
bringing people on
for a shorter period
and getting them active
on the team early.
Have any of you guys tried
that at your companies?
SHALIN AMIN: The
try-it-before-you-buy-it kind
of concept?
BRYNN EVANS: Yeah.
And also, how do candidates
feel in that position?
SHALIN AMIN: Yeah.
We've done that with a
couple of candidates.
And we've found
typically that helps
for them to understand the
culture, the pace of work
at which we produce stuff.
And it's very different at a
Dropbox or a Pinterest versus
Uber.
So just as much as
they're evaluating us,
we're evaluating them as well.
And so I think it's a
fair ask to do that.
And it's nice.
It's easy to have
those conversations
at the end of the three months,
or doing those check-ins
every month and being like,
hey, how are you feeling?
Are you feeling supported?
Are things working for you?
Are you finding success
in your project?
Do you like working
with engineers or PMs?
So you get to answer all
that and just not having
as much risk, which
is kind of nice.
But generally, we
find people that
jump on right after
the three-month period.
DANIEL BURKA: A few years ago,
I was considering my options,
and I went and talked to one of
the big kids in the Bay Area.
And the CEO said to my
face, he said, listen,
you're not getting
married to us.
Come and try it
for three months.
And I was like, that was
a baller thing to say.
It was not what I expected.
I thought he was
like, join our team.
You're going to be happy here
for the rest of your life.
And I was very tempted
to actually try it.
So it's a unique pitch.
BRYNN EVANS: Yeah.
For sure.
SOLEIO CUERVO: And
it's a good way
to scale needs for
the organization,
especially if you're going
through a growth stage
and you know that there's
just a laundry list of things
you wish you were working on.
That can align really well
with some terrific freelancers
that are out there.
It gives you an opportunity
to just introduce
some diversity of thought
and process into your team,
even if it doesn't net
out to a full-time hire.
We've just found a
tremendous amount of success
both in terms of
staffing projects,
getting awesome
experiences out the door,
and then ultimately converting
them to full-time hires.
When we had our first developer
conference in this building,
we basically contacted this
tremendous illustrator,
Ryan Putnam, who ultimately
joined the team by virtue
of his exposure to
Dropbox through the lens
of that project.
We were able to get
the project done.
And more importantly,
we were able to achieve
a great full-time hire.
BRYNN EVANS: So
I wonder how this
plays into the
next topic I wanted
to talk about a little
bit, senior designers
versus junior designers.
It feels like maybe with
the exception of you,
Daniel, being offered
a three-month gig,
you're not getting
married to this company.
It seems great for
junior designers
or new designers
getting started.
They want to just
try out a few options
or not commit to anything.
But also, how do you source
for really senior talent?
I found this to be particularly
challenging myself.
I have a lot of senior
designer friends,
but they're very
happy in their jobs.
What do you do?
SOLEIO CUERVO: You never say no.
BRYNN EVANS: OK.
SOLEIO CUERVO: I think
there's a certain amount
of relentlessness
that comes with it.
I think, going back to
what I was saying earlier
about understanding
core motivation,
you need to-- everybody
here in this room
has a career trajectory.
Everybody sort of has
a thesis in their head
of what they can accomplish
in their professional careers,
like why they entered
design in the first place,
and how that's going
to play out over time.
I think a key part of
it is understanding
what the trajectory
looks like, figuring out,
does it align with my
business, with my team?
Is there a great fit here?
And then painting that picture.
There's this concept,
inception, that
was popularized with this movie.
But I actually think that it
directly applies to recruiting.
You have to create a scenario
where a person clearly
understands their
role on the team,
how it aligns with
their individual story,
and how they can achieve
growth in your organization.
But most important
of all, you have
to be able to actually
realize that growth.
You need to be able to make
that promise and deliver on it.
Because I think designers,
creatives can smell bullshit.
And so I think it's
really important for you
to be able to actually
demonstrate how a person can
grow and achieve that thesis,
achieve that storyline
in your organization.
MIA BLUME: I think part of it
is, again, it's the long game.
You have to be willing to
wait for the right timing.
So if you know that that
junior designer wants
to be a part of the
team, you probably
have a lot more
opportunities for them
to engage on a project.
But senior designers,
they do have a story.
They've been somewhere.
There's certain
things that they're
looking to work on next.
And so sometimes, it's just
about having that business
opportunity in your
project and getting
them aligned on that, which
means that more often than not,
you have to have a very specific
pitch for that senior designer,
which is, hey, you're
going to be working on this
with these people, and this is
the impact that we foresee you
having on the company
and the product.
DANIEL BURKA: And frankly,
to source senior talent,
there's nothing wrong
with going and approaching
the people you love, whether
or not they have a current job.
And you don't have to poach
them by carrying around
two big bags of cash, like
putting it on their table.
But talk to them about
the role that you're
looking to fill,
and then ask them
who they'd hire
for the position.
Because either they're going to
step up and say, you know what?
To tell you the truth,
I'm not very happy
where I am right now, and
that sounds [BLEEP] cool.
Yeah, I'm interested.
Or even if they're
not interested,
ask them who the three people
they'd hire for that position.
Go start the conversation
with those people.
It's a great way to kind
of work your way out.
But hiring senior
talent is just hard.
It's really hard.
And if you're not
putting in the leg work,
you're not going
to get good people.
SOLEIO CUERVO: I would
piggyback on that.
Designers collect
designers, and they
would, more often than
not, just tell you
who are the great folks
they should be talking to.
Curiously enough, we hired
Evan Sharp to Facebook
by virtue of a
referral like that.
We had actually reached out
to somebody in New York,
and they were like, I'm not
interested in a role there,
but you should talk to
this guy, Evan Sharp.
And lo and behold,
he ended up making
a great hire and
ultimately a great founder.
But that one degree away
is just free information.
And if you're not getting
that free information
with every single
recruiting conversation
that you're having, you're just
throwing away valuable intel.
SHALIN AMIN: So just
to jump in real quick.
So part of the thing that Mia
talked about around building
a story and listening,
I think it's
really important for
senior level talent
to really listen
and figure out, what
was their story before they
joined the last company?
What are they getting out of it?
What's missing?
And then to try to format a
sales pitch or the story that
aligns around your
culture, your goals,
and seeing how they
could potentially fit in.
Like painting a better
picture for them, essentially.
I think what
designers really want
is to solve really
hard problems.
And I think as long as you make
it about problems and not about
money, I think you're going
to have a lot of success.
But it's really actively
listening to where they are,
where they want to go.
How will Uber or
some other company
format that story for them, and
really pitching it that way.
We've found success.
BRYNN EVANS: You guys touched
on this for a brief moment--
poaching and hiring ethics.
And I think this is tricky.
Designers do collect designers.
And when you leave,
you want to bring
the best people
you know with you.
But I think there
is a fine line.
How do you know when
to lay off, when
to be more gentle
about who you go after?
But you also want to
build a great team.
Do you have examples of
either you've tried this
and it's been successful?
Or you've tried this
and you actually
got slapped on the hand,
or there was an incident?
MIA BLUME: You call it
poaching, I call it recruiting.
Great designers have great jobs.
It's a really great
time for all of us
right now to work on a
lot of awesome stuff.
And so yes, there
are legal things
that you should
definitely avoid in terms
of recruiting designers.
But hey, if they're
excited about your product
and your team, and you're
excited about them,
there's no harm in
having a conversation.
BRYNN EVANS: OK.
DANIEL BURKA: I'm not going
to do anything underhanded
if I'm trying to hire somebody.
I'm expecting that
if I went and chatted
with them about the
job, they're going
to go tell their boss,
potentially, hey,
Burka's trying to get
me to come do something.
So if I'm poaching
people from Twitter,
I don't want Mike Davidson--
he knows where I live.
He can mess with me.
But there's nothing
wrong with having
a conversation with
somebody and just
talking about how
interesting something is.
I talk to Googlers and chat to
them about their current job.
I'm not going to go
poaching people from Google.
But if they're looking
for their next thing,
it's a great opportunity.
BRYNN EVANS: Yup.
So moving on.
Sourcing is clearly a challenge.
And I think we all
agree that there's not
one clear solution that's
going to make this really easy
for us.
But we still do a
pretty good job.
Your teams are pretty
well developed.
What do you look
for when designers
come on to your teams?
So in the first week
or the first month,
do you have a process for
welcoming them, onboarding
them, getting them involved
with the rest of the team
that's been successful
or unsuccessful?
MIA BLUME: For us
at Pinterest, we
do a couple of different
things, and we've tried things
over the past months, years.
Sometimes they are successful,
sometimes they're not.
We try and have a culture buddy.
And we don't call it a culture
buddy, but basically someone,
another designer
on the team, that's
there to look out
for them-- take them
to really important sessions,
meetings, cultural moments they
may not know about yet.
But also, be there
to answer questions.
Because sometimes
going to a leader
on their team, their
manager, it might
be a little bit intimidating
at the beginning.
Things that we start
to look for early on
is if they're not asking
really tough questions
in the first couple
weeks, I'm not
sure they're paying attention.
So I'm actually really
excited that designers
are asking tough questions.
How does this work?
That seems weird.
What's going on here?
It means they're observing.
They're digging in.
They're meeting
the right people.
And part of that is
setting them up for success
and giving guidance on, hey, you
should go talk to these people.
You should get engaged in these
certain programs or projects,
and just kind of absorb.
And so the questions
that come out of that
are really important.
The other thing
that we try and do
is get them on project
as fast as possible
so that they're
engaged in the work.
That doesn't mean we expect them
to ship something on day two,
although that's great.
We want them to be
involved in the project
and know who their
teammates are.
That's really important
for them to absorb.
SOLEIO CUERVO: I think the
highest [? ordered ?] [? bit ?]
is to always actively
invest in it.
Even if you're really
starved for resources
and it'd be really hard
to carve out 10% to 20%
of a person's time to
onboard a new designer,
it's such a crucial investment.
One, you need to be able
to just assimilate them
into the culture, expose
them to the problems
that are being worked on,
introduce them to teams,
real hard work.
Get a sense of whether
or not the person's
going to be the sort of fit
that you had anticipated.
Because you had probably
spent n hours evaluating them
over the course of
interviews, but that's
going to pale in comparison
to the first week of work
that they conduct.
And so I think it's
really important
to align them with a buddy.
At Dropbox, we
called it your DFF,
your Design Friend Forever.
And you have a DFF
assigned ahead of time.
That person would be
responsible not just
for conducting all
of the social 101s
and taking you
around the building,
but they're also going to
be responsible for vetting
projects, introducing
you to the stakeholders
for those projects, and
making sure you're getting
your work done within
your first couple weeks.
I think that the onboarding
process varies according
to the life stage of
a particular company.
When Dropbox was a lot smaller,
we sort of did the round robin.
Give me the projects
that are unstaffed,
and we'll find the ones that
are scoped well enough for you.
And we'll try to parcel it
up into a six-week program
or residency for
that new designer.
As Dropbox has
scaled, we've been
much more proactive
about aligning designers
to particular design clusters
so that they basically
get integrated into the team
that we anticipate them landing
in, and more importantly,
getting a sense of how
their technical
fits is incorporated
into that particular
design cluster.
BRYNN EVANS: I'm similarly
interested in the senior
versus junior position here.
Because on the team
that I just left,
a pretty senior designer joined.
And he really didn't get
assigned a mentor or a buddy,
because he was very senior.
And he specifically came
in to help run the team.
And he came to me and asked for
advice, and I gave him advice.
It was no problem.
And then he
continually came to me,
and I started becoming
his de facto mentor, which
I was perfectly happy to do.
But he was much senior to me.
And I realized that either
he was lost in the cracks,
or we just weren't
paying as much attention
to him, because
he was so senior.
But I think the kind
of guidance he needed
was maybe more organizational,
less around craft, and UX,
and feedback on specific work.
But even still, we
needed to pay attention
to getting senior designers
up to speed, and active,
and engaged, too.
And I'm curious what
you guys have tried.
Shalin, have you tried
stuff with senior designers
that are different from junior?
SHALIN AMIN: Yeah.
I mean, for us, it's
a little different.
So by that chart, we
have a lot of priorities
in building design discipline.
When I started at
Uber, it was literally
like there was no onboarding.
It was just like, hey,
I need a computer.
They're like, there's an
Apple store across the street.
Go get it and expense it.
I need some Post-it notes.
Well, there's an Office Depot.
Go get it.
And at a very early
stage, I think it's OK.
But as we start to develop
into a more mature company,
I think these onboarding
processes or boot
camps are super useful.
We're getting better about
our onboarding process,
but I don't think
we're there yet.
I think we have a pool
of talented designers
that new hires can rely on.
We now have these
programs in which
there are multiple
designers on a single team.
So when we put a
designer on that team,
the program is
essentially expected
to onboard and ramp them up.
And we're not necessarily
looking for somebody
to produce anything
in a couple of days.
But more often than
not, we've found people
just being like, put
me in the game, coach.
I want to build something.
I want to do something.
So as long as they
have that passion,
we're not going to let
that get in the way.
But in all honesty, I think we
can be better about onboarding.
But we're not there yet.
BRYNN EVANS: So
I'm wondering also
about happiness, and spirit, and
culture of the team in general.
Have you guys tried anything
experimental or crazy
to keep your teams happy, like
outside of work, off-sites,
things like that?
Interesting activities?
MIA BLUME: For us at Pinterest,
we do a lot cultural events,
whether it's really small
stuff or design team off-sites.
In general, we're a
very makerly culture.
And the team is very passionate
about their different interest
areas beyond design.
For instance, we
started this small thing
that is not just for designers
but the larger company called
Studio Nights.
We have a design studio that's
dedicated to the creative team,
but we wanted to open that
up to the larger company.
And so we basically had one
individual teach a small class
one of their skills
or interest areas
to other people at the company.
It was a great way for a
rapidly scaling startup
to get to know each
other, to make things,
to have fun, have a beer.
So we did everything from
beekeeping to GitHub 101
to bookbinding,
all kinds of stuff.
And so that was a really great
way to get people engaged.
As a design team, we
also get out a lot,
because we're rapidly growing.
And it's really important
for us to not only have
social connections but be on the
same path as the design team.
Understand where we're
headed, what we believe in,
because there's going to be
a lot of new people coming in
and different perspectives,
which is great.
It will stretch and
grow our perspectives.
But we also want
to be in alignment
in terms of where we're headed
and what we're building.
DANIEL BURKA: To
be honest, I think
that some of these off-site
things are kind of BS.
It feels good.
And I know a team that
took the whole team,
and they got on a plane,
and went to Los Angeles,
and went to the Eames House.
And that sounds fun.
I like going places,
and that's cool.
But I think lots of
teams do this stuff where
they do team-building exercises,
and they do, like, fun.
And again, I like fun.
Fun's fun.
MIA BLUME: Nobody likes
mandatory fun time, though.
DANIEL BURKA:
Mandatory fun time.
Yeah.
It takes all the fun out of it.
It's true.
But I think that if you're
going to do this stuff,
I think there is
some value to it.
I think it's
overrated a bit, but I
think there's some value to it.
If you're going to
do it, do things
where it helps you get in
the mind space of your users.
Pinterest has obvious
places to do that.
I'm trying to think
of some good examples.
But there's lots
of exercises you
can do that help you
understand users.
But the best team-building
stuff is doing great projects
together, like work
projects-- things
you ship, and you succeeded.
And then go out and
celebrate together.
That's another great
way to build team unity.
But these BS off-site
barbecue, let's all
do three-legged races,
and build our teams.
Like, [BLEEP] off.
[LAUGHTER]
[SOME APPLAUSE]
SHALIN AMIN: Claps.
You have five
people on your team.
DANIEL BURKA: No.
I've worked on teams that
are bigger than five people.
I love my team, if you're here.
Let's go do three-legged races.
SHALIN AMIN: I
think my perspective
on that is slightly skewed
and a little different.
So for me, team outside
bonding exercises
are-- you can work on
projects, and that's great,
but you're working
with a core of, like,
five people at a time.
You're not getting to interact
with the other 40 designers
that you have around you.
And I think part of it is
building a shared experience
together.
So we have a designer at
Uber who did-- last holiday,
she did a gingerbread
house-making contest.
And everybody was
super down on it.
It was like one of
those forced fun
kind of things at
the very beginning.
But by the time we finished it,
I think the entire experience,
it was not only working with
four new people on your team,
but building in a common goal.
At the end of it,
we were laughing.
We were talking about
some of the mistakes
that we made, some of the cool
things that we had come out
of the gingerbread houses.
And I don't know.
It was just really
things that were not
related to work or to users.
And I think designers
at Uber, especially,
they think about
work all the time.
So what is that natural thing
that we can do beyond drinking,
I think, is also important.
MIA BLUME: One of
the things that I
would encourage as you
think about your off-site is
time to make together.
That doesn't have to be just
barbecues, or rollerskating,
or whatever you do for
the mandatory fun stuff.
So two off-sites, for
example, that we did.
The first one, when the
team was really young--
it was just a handful of
us-- part of our off-site
was to think about what are the
characteristics that we want
our design team to be, and
what do we want to grow into.
So we talked a lot
about what environments
made us successful,
what made us happy.
And we basically did our own
design exercise around the team
that we want to build, which
influenced who we hired,
the environment that
we created as we grew.
Another example is, we had
an afternoon where we all
wanted to work on
this one project.
It wasn't a priority
for the company.
And we said, you know what?
We're going to go away, and
we're going to work on it.
So we were working, but we
were bonding over a project
that we wanted to work on.
And some really cool
stuff came out of that.
So I think there's a
way to balance that.
And maybe this comes from
my consulting background.
There's a lot of effort that
goes into running a workshop,
and this is basically a
workshop with your team.
So the effort that
you put into it
is the return that you'll get.
DANIEL BURKA: Yeah.
I like that, though.
You set a base of,
this is serious fun.
You're actually getting
something productive out
at the end of it.
That's great.
MIA BLUME: Serious fun.
SOLEIO CUERVO: But
to echo your point,
I think the best
way to retain talent
at the end of the day is to
challenge them on things that
are going to matter
to the business.
Give them the opportunity
to take that winning shot,
and make sure that they
celebrate when they hit it.
I think at the end
of the day, doing
great work is what keeps
people happy, is what keeps
people engaged.
Everything else is not going
to substitute for that.
All the office perks, off-sites,
the fun little brunches,
that doesn't matter as much as
shipping software that changes
people's lives and holding
people accountable for that,
and making sure that they
celebrate it when they do it.
When they finally get
across that milestone,
make sure you're throwing
the biggest party in town,
because they need
to recognize that,
at the end of the
day, that's why you're
at that organization, is
to achieve those goals.
BRYNN EVANS: Yup.
As you're talking,
it's making me
think that a lot
of our effort is
spent on keeping our
teams happy and engaged
and putting the right
sort of cultural values
into our teams, which will
then lead towards finding
the right talents, building
the teams in the ways
that you want.
I'm curious.
Soleio, you at Dropbox
were trying specifically
to put the culture
directly in the team
before looking for talent.
And when you choose
where to spend your time,
sourcing or
team-building, how do you
decide where to spend
most of your time?
Where is it going
to be most valuable?
SOLEIO CUERVO: I think
at the end of the day,
it's trying to set up culture
around the things that
are going to matter, not
just for a particular quarter
or a particular
year, but over time.
What is it that's going
to be the differentiator
for your business, not just
from a recruiting standpoint,
but also just from a
competitive standpoint?
And make sure that the
culture feeds through that.
And going back to
the hiring attributes
that we were talking about,
at the end of the day,
Dropbox is in the business
of storing people's most
important information
and bringing it to life.
And so that requires people to
be able to sweat the details
and really just cultivate a
culture around that, but also
just to be able
to be trustworthy,
be people who are going to
be open, honest, and earnest.
And making sure that you're
rewarding that day to day, not
just in terms of individual
actions, but also
trying to cultivate programs
and acknowledging that,
OK, for us to be able
to sweat the details
and build the best
quality products,
we care about diversity.
So we're going to set these
specific goals around it.
And every time we have that
recruiting pipeline meeting,
we're going to be
measuring how we're
tracking towards those goals.
And making sure
that you're not just
saying that you're paying
attention to something
or caring about it,
but you're actually
showing results against it.
BRYNN EVANS: OK.
I'm curious if there's any
questions from the audience.
Anything that we
haven't covered?
MIA BLUME: Yay. [LAUGHS]
SOLEIO CUERVO: Are we the
first to have questions?
SHALIN AMIN: I hope so.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
BRYNN EVANS: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm curious how you recommend
prioritizing diversity when
you're looking for designers.
DANIEL BURKA: That is
an excellent question,
first of all.
BRYNN EVANS: Were you
going to take it away?
SHALIN AMIN: In all
honesty, we were
talking about this
backstage, and we
were debating whether
we should bring this up.
But thank you for bringing
that up, actually.
I guess we could tee it off.
Burka had brought up the
conversation around diversity,
and he was kind of nervous
about just even bringing
the conversation up, which led
us to some great discussions
around-- diversity, I
think, is an important part
in the hiring process.
And it takes rigor,
and it takes intention.
It doesn't come easy.
And so I think in hiring within
the entire design discipline
or within the organization,
you have to make time for it.
It means you have to increase
your pool of candidates
and work harder at finding
a more diverse set of people
versus the ones that you're
just automatically going
to get through your
hiring pipeline.
Do you want to share any?
DANIEL BURKA: Boy, you
really set me up here.
SHALIN AMIN: Yeah, I know.
DANIEL BURKA: I
commiserate with anybody
who finds this uncomfortable.
I mean, it's really difficult
to talk about this stuff
without feeling like you're
marginalizing people,
and without talking
about it, like you're
talking about a specific group.
And I think one of
the good suggestions
is to not think of it
like, we need more women!
And then, oh, I've got
folders full of women!
Who was that?
Mitt Romney, I think, said that?
SOLEIO CUERVO: Binders.
DANIEL BURKA: Binders
full of women.
BRYNN EVANS: Binders, yeah.
DANIEL BURKA: Is
to think about it,
I think, a bit more broadly,
and to think about diversity
generally, like where
are your people from?
Do they have a diverse set
of background experiences?
They could be different
language experiences,
different-- there's all
kinds of areas of diversity.
And then you don't
fall into that trap
where you feel like you're
kind of categorizing
everybody and getting
yourself in trouble, I guess.
MIA BLUME: One of the
things I mentioned
earlier is thinking about
the composition of your team.
And to the idea of having
different profiles,
I think you constantly
need to be assessing,
hey, what are different
qualities, and aspects,
and backgrounds that are going
to make our design team better?
Without singling out a
specific gender or race,
it's about what is going
to help us grow as a team?
And that may include gender and
race, depending on your team.
But go beyond that,
and constantly
be looking beyond
your assumptions
of what's right for the team.
And that means that you may
have to take some risks.
That means that you
may have to hire people
that you wouldn't normally hire.
And that leads me
to the next point,
which is it's not enough just
to hit your numbers and say,
great.
We set a goal, we
are now more diverse.
But actually to follow
through and make sure
that those people are engaged,
and getting into the work,
and getting into the team.
Because that's where
it really matters.
Are you hiring them, and
are they staying engaged?
And do they actually
make the team better?
SOLEIO CUERVO: And a good
way to start the conversation
within a design organization
is just to wind the clock back.
One thing that's
amazing about this space
is that people's backgrounds
in design today are so diverse.
I mean, it's not like we
all went to design school.
Folks are coming from
different backgrounds,
different motivation centers.
And you ask yourself, how would
I have identified myself out
of the sea of people out there
in the world five years ago?
Because there are more
people like that out there.
And in order for us
to grow this industry
and grow the design
discipline, we
need to look outside of the
known quantities of people that
are already in tech
organizations for talent.
We're going to have to start to
look much further beyond just
Silicon Valley and
thinking about who
are the international candidates
that we should be hiring.
What are the emergent schools
that we should be hiring from?
Are they architecture schools?
Are they schools that
aren't even teaching design?
Maybe it's computer science.
And I think that's going to have
to be the competitive advantage
that any hiring
manager cultivates
within their team, is, again,
having an open conversation
around, OK, how many of you
guys went to design school?
Raise your hands.
A lot, but not everyone.
And I think that's
worth noting when
it comes to sourcing and
to cultivating talent,
and shining a
really bright beacon
towards this line of work.
I think at the end of the
day, the chief responsibility
that every person
in this room has
is indicating that there is
tremendous careers in design
and tech.
Two, that it's just very
fulfilling work, but then
more importantly, that this is
something you can actually get
paid to do.
And I don't think
that as a community,
we're doing enough to
communicate that message
to people early enough
in their careers.
Every 18-year-old should
know that they can actually
be a software designer.
They can actually pursue
this as a career path.
BRYNN EVANS: We probably have
time for one more question.
I see a few.
SOLEIO CUERVO: That guy.
BRYNN EVANS: This guy.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
That's loud.
Hi.
BRYNN EVANS: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So you guys
talked a little bit
about hiring junior people
versus senior people.
And I know that one thing I
hear all the time from people
who are hiring is, it's
so hard to hire people,
it's so hard to find
people and source people.
But I also know that
there's a lot of people
who are fresh out of
school who are, like, it's
impossible to find
a job, I can't
find anyone who will hire me.
So there seems to
be a disconnect
between organizations'
ability to hire junior people.
So I wondered if each
of you could talk about,
in organizations
you've been a part of,
what's the number one roadblock
to hiring junior people to more
roles?
MIA BLUME: We were talking
about this earlier.
I think one of
the things that we
found-- because this is a
discipline that is evolving,
there's a lot of terms
being thrown around--
are you a UX designer,
product designer, whatever?
I know that must be really
confusing for people right out
of school to figure out
how to position themselves.
So there are definitely a
bunch of awesome startups
and resources for
those designers
to get involved in,
like Designer Fund.
But one of the things
that we do on our team
is make sure that
we give feedback
to every single candidate.
Hey, this is what we
saw in your portfolio.
We actually think
your strength is this,
and there's an
opportunity for you
to grow in these other areas.
And help them shape
their narrative.
And even though that might not
be a right match for us right
now, hopefully, we're
giving them something
to propel them forward to the
next opportunity, whether it's
at Pinterest or somewhere else.
So I think there's work
to be done on both sides.
SOLEIO CUERVO: I think
the leading obstacle is
the perception that it's--
I think a lot of folks take
so much pride in doing the work
that they don't recognize how
leveraged it is to set aside 20%
of your time to helping nurture
and grow others.
And every design
manager should be
thinking about instilling
a culture of growth,
not just in terms
of sheer headcount,
but in terms of
growing your people,
accelerating their career
paths within your building,
within your team,
and making sure
that you're thinking
about that as the most
leveraged opportunity.
Because what you'll
find that comes from
it is that mentorship is
a natural part of growth.
And if you can create a culture
of mentorship within your team,
you're going to be able to have
the infrastructure in place
to absorb a lot more talents
and to take calculated gambles
on people who are just
going to be coming out
of school, saying, I don't
really have much experience.
My portfolio is this.
I'm eager to learn.
I'm going to work my ass off,
but will you please hire me?
And I think that's the
leading obstacle that I've
seen across not just the
branding and tech companies
but across all of
tech, is that we
can't make enough
calculated gambles,
because there isn't the
culture of mentorship,
and that it really starts with
design managers emphasizing
growth within their
organizations.
DANIEL BURKA: That's exactly
what I was going to say.
It's a ratio between
mentors and mentees.
And junior designers, by
definition, need mentorship.
And the advice I always
give junior designers
when I have coffee
with them is, find
one person who you
can see as a mentor,
and try to work with them.
You don't have to
work with a big team.
It doesn't really matter.
Being able to sit next to
somebody who can mentor you
is easily the best way to learn.
And one way I think that
especially smaller teams can
potentially take a risk
on junior designers--
because that's really
what it is, is you're
an unproven quantity--
is potentially
look outside of your business
for potential mentors.
Bring in somebody as an
advisor to your business who's
a senior designer who's willing
to put aside two hours a week
to come and work with
your junior designer.
That way, you can take
the risk but still
have somebody who's able to
cultivate that young designer
and bring them along.
That's something we try to do
as the GV team a little bit.
If our startups hire
a junior designer,
then we'll spend a bit of time
working with them all the time
and giving them that critical
critique and feedback.
But I don't think that's just
limited to that situation.
I think you can--
especially in San Francisco,
there's such a wealth
of senior designers
to leverage that
type of mentorship.
And if you're a
senior designer, I'm
sure you learned by
learning from mentors.
Critique them.
Be honest with them, and
help bring them along.
Because that, I think,
is our responsibility
as senior designers.
SOLEIO CUERVO: It's
so much more effective
than writing blog posts.
I think a lot of it just
involves identifying folks
out there who really
want to do great work
and spending the time with them.
I think every
person in this room
can think back on
great teachers,
and I often believe
that designers and tech
underestimate their potential
as teachers for others.
BRYNN EVANS: I love that.
We are out of time, but I
think that's a great way
to wrap up the panel.
Thank you guys so much.
SOLEIO CUERVO:
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]